الم يكن هذا الاعلان من قبل المحكمه
مفاجئا سيد فادي العبد الله
المحكمه تقوم بعملها وفقا لما يقدمه
المدعي العام من ادله وبالطلبات وبعد ذلك
القضاه يعني
ينظرون فيه ويصدرون قرارهم في افضل مده
ممكنه
لكن في هذا القرار ما المترتب عليها سيده
فادي عبد الله
القرار يقضي باصدار
اوامر بالقبض على
شخصين السيد بوتين وساده بدوره وذلك بتهم
تتعلق بالنقل القصري للاطفال
بالدرجه الاولى من اراضي اوكرانيه الى
اراضي روسيه بناء على ذلك يعني يصبح هؤلاء
شخصان مشتبه بهما في نظر المحكمه وتطلب
المحكمه بناء على ذلك من الدول المساعده
في تنفيذ هذه
الاوامر قبل وبالتالي هنالك الدول التي هي
منضمه الى نظام المحكمه والتي لديها واجب
قانوني وفقا لهذه المعاهده بالتعاون مع
المحكمه بما في ذلك تنفيذ اوامر القبض اذا
كان المجتمع به او المشتغل بهما على اراضي
هذه الدوله هنالك اراد هنالك دول اخرى
ليست منضمه الى نظام المحكمه هذه الحاله
يكون عندها خيار التعاون طوعا او عدم
التعاون مع المحكمه لتنفيذ هذه الاوامر
لكن سيد فادي عبد الله من حيث
بنظر القانون الدولي
الاوكرانيا وروسيا الفيدراليه ليستا
دول
عضوه في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
روسيا ليست دوله
النظر في دعاوى من دوله غير غير عضو في
المحكمه بشان خصم غير عضو ايضا في المحكمه
عدد من نقاط ينبغي توضيحها اولا الدعوه
يقيمها المدعي العام للمحكمه وليس دوله ضد
دوله يعني هذه القضيه ليست بناء على اتهام
من اوكرانيا وانه بناء على المدعي العام
للمحكمه وهذه نقطه مهمه لان المحكمه لا
تفصل في النزاعات بين الدول ولكن في
نزاعات تتعلق بمسؤوليه جرميه او بالاشتباه
بالمسؤوليه شرميه هذه النقطه النقطه
الثانيه هنالك اختلاف بين روسيا واوكرانيا
بالنسبه للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
الدولتان لم تنضم الى المعاهده ولكن
اوكرانيا قدمت مرتين اعلانا من الحكومه
الاوكرانيه يفيد بقبولها اختصاص المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه في شان ما يمكن ان يرتكب
على اراضيها او من قبل مواطنيها وهذا
الاعلان هو اعلان يوازي في مفعوله
القانوني كانه انضمام الى المعاهده من دون
المرور بالتصديق البرلماني عليها